il ya toujours des problèmes de
transparence au niveau des crypto
monnaie il ya aussi beaucoup de
problèmes de désinformation je pense ce
qui rend fait l'investissement dans ces
choses là c'est difficile moi je pense
que si quelqu'un veut vraiment
se lancer dans l'écriture monnaie
il faut vraiment qu'ils comprennent très
bien dans quoi il se lance
[Musique]
avaleur de foot monnaies et beaucoup
basé sur la notion de confiance sur la
notion de le sentiment de l'investisseur
donc est ce qu un sentiment positif
par rapport à ces investissements la
psychologie donc c'est facile d'aller
sur les réseaux sociaux puis de lancer
une mauvaise rumeur ou décide d'inventer
quelque chose puis de promouvoir une
nouvelle crypte aux monnaies mais sur
des bases frauduleuse le donc c'est très
c'est très risqué à ce niveau là
[Musique]
l'exemple de terol la théorie c'est
qu'il y aurait un investisseur important
car essayer de manipuler les prix donc
car essayer de retirer son
investissement trop rapidement ce qui
aurait créé un déséquilibre en fait sur
le marché puis ça aurait causé une crise
de confiance et puis les investisseurs
se seraient retirés c'est
essentiellement une version moderne de
panique bancaire puis finalement c'est
même pas important de savoir si ça s'est
vraiment produit ou non juste le fait
qu'une rumeur ça peut causer justement
une panne et puis le retrait des
investissements
en pendant longtemps les gens disaient
20g cryptome justement un refuge contre
l'inflation comparaissent à beaucoup
alors les sites ainsi on voit des pires
épisodes d'inflation depuis très
longtemps puis comme par hasard dans un
même temps les les crypto monnaies sont
en train de perdre beaucoup de valeur en
même temps que je pense qu'on peut en
partie expliquer sa part le film que ça
devient de plus en plus mines situées
l'une des plus en plus des grandes
questions financières commencent à
investir dans les cryptes aux monnaies
ça a beaucoup changé en fait le profil
de l'investisseur ça a beaucoup changé
la psychologie des investisseurs
derrière ses troupes tout le monde est
là et donc je pense que ça change
quelque part de la dynamique du prix
comment ça réagit par rapport aux autres
barrières économiques donc à la valeur
des actions des obligations et puis de
l'inflation par exemple
[Musique]
parce que la chute récente avoir un
impact parce que encore une fois c'est
ce genre de variation qu'on a vue qui je
ne décrirai pas comme ça anormal c'est
sûr que si vous n'êtes pas prête à
perdre 20% 30% d'ici un mois ou deux ben
c'est peut-être pas un risque que vous
êtes capable de prendre donc quand vous
investissez dans l'équipe de monnaie
c'est vraiment pour un investissement
long terme pour pas regardé à tous les
jours voir ce que ça monte et ça descend
là c'est quelque chose c'est un pari un
parce que y'a rien qui dit que dans le
futur les crypto monnaies vont vraiment
adopté de façon plus large quand vous
investi là-dedans c'est le pari que vous
êtes en train de prendre le pari
pourrait bien tourner prêterait gagné
avec l'équipe promener comme pourriez
tout perdre est essentielle
[Musique]
si on veut se lancer là dedans c'est un
peu moi je donne un peu l'exemple de la
sauce piquante à la sauce piquante on
peut remettre un peu sur notre notre
poche ça peut rehausser un peu le goût
est donc là que décrypte aux monnaies
dont on a juste un petit peu notre son
portefeuille ça peut être juste un petit
peu de diversification ça peut rajouter
des rendements importants mais il faut
garder ça vraiment comme étant une
petite proportion et ça dépend aussi
beaucoup le de notre tolérance au risque
donc plus on est tolérant au risque deux
fois plus on est jeune plus la retraite
c'est loin puis on est capable de
prendre des paris un petit peu plus
risqué vous avez oublié que les crypto
monnaie ça paye ça paie pas de
dividendes ça fait aucun revenu
d'intérêt donc on est vraiment en train
de miser sur un gain en capital
on est vraiment à miser sur le fait qu'
on veut que la valeur du type de monnaie
augmente dans le temps et c'est le pari
qu'ont
[Musique]